– [Zac] Jamie Lloyd was born in late 1980 or early to
mid 1981. We know this because Jamie is first
introduced to us at 4am on October 31st in
1988, where she is referred to as being seven
years old. Jamie’s mother was Laurie Strode
and her father was a man with the last name
Lloyd… and that’s pretty much all that’s pretty
much all we ever learn about him. Jamie had
what seems like a pretty happy childhood for
the first seven years of her life. However,
in November of 1987, her mother and
father are killed in an accident.
– I know you miss your
parents. It hasn’t been that long.
– It’s been eleven months.
– Jamie was adopted by Darlene and Richard
Carruthers, who knew Jamie’s family
because Laurie once babysat for their own
daughter, Rachel, who is now a teenager.
Jamie clings to her new adoptive sister –
a similarity she shares with Andy Barclay
from Child’s Play, who I’ve talked about
on a previous episode of Horror History.
Jamie pleads with Rachel to
love her like a real sister,
as she tries to find where she fits in with hernew
adopted family. While Rachel and Jamie do form
a special bond, their time together
would quite literally be cut short.
To find out more about why Jamie
copes the way she does with the
trauma caused by her Uncle -- Haddonfield
boogeyman Michael Myers -- and the long
term psychological effects he causes,
stick around to the end of this video.
(metal music)
Welcome to Horror History. Jamie Lloyd does not
need an unstoppable killing machine to come after
her in order to gain some psychological
issues. When we first meet her character,
played by the then unknown actress Danielle
Harris, she is struggling to cope with the
recent loss of her parents, and, perhaps
as a result, suffers chronic insomnia.
– [Rachel] Kiddo. It’s four in the morning.
– [Jamie] I can’t sleep.
– What is this, four nights in a row?
Are you going for a record here? The
seven year old insomniac’s hall of fame?
– Despite Rachel trivializing the mental
illness of an innocent agonized orphan,
according to The Child Mind Institute; “symptoms
of trauma in children closely mimic depression,
including too much or too little sleep.” That
probably explains Jamie’s difficulty with sleep,
but her issues may go deeper than what
meets the eye. To understand her behavior,
we also need to analyze her mother,
Laurie Strode, so let’s take it back
to that fateful Halloween night in 1978,
when Laurie was take- en-to-the hos-pit-al.
(mysterious music)
As I mentioned in my Things You
Missed episode on Halloween II,
Laurie has a deep seated fear of going to sleep,
which I interpreted as her subconscious
being scared to dream about Michael Myers.
Just like Laurie, Jamie avoids sleeping
due in part to her own fear of nightmares
involving Michael. After being convinced
to go to bed by Rachel in the early hours
of the morning on Halloween, Jamie suffers
from nightmares of Michael coming after her
in her room. Although they have never
met, Jamie already knows what the adult Michael
Myers looks like. It’s almost as if her
mother’s trauma was passed down to her.
We don’t know how Laurie and Jamie’s father raised
their child. They may have shielded her from
finding out about the horrible crimes her uncle
committed, or they may have done the opposite
and tried to warn her and teach her about him,
with concern that he could one day escape again.
Jamie is part of the original Halloween
timeline, but Laurie also has a kid
both in the 20 and 40 year timelines.
Because those are different continuities,
they are essentially different versions
of the Laurie Strode character, but if
this Laurie is anything like those Lauries she
would have prepared Jamie for Michael’s return.
In fact, in the 40 year timeline,
Laurie has a daughter named Karen,
who she trains to use firearms and is
extremely strict with in regards to her safety.
Rumor has it that in the original script of
Halloween (2018), Karen’s name was Jamie,
as if she were an alternate version
of Jamie Lloyd. I guess in the end,
they were worried that this would be
too confusing so she’s now a Karen.
– [Karen] Hey mom... I thought you quit drinking?
(Laurie grunts)
– [Karen] This is exactly why we don't reach out.
– But back to our Jamie. If her mother wasn’t
the one to inform her about Michael Myers,
her classmates made sure she knew about
her embarrassing family connection.
– [Jamie] I don’t need to wear a stupid costume.
– [Boy] That’s because every day is Halloween at
Jamie’s house! Right, Jamie? Because
your uncle’s the boogeyman!
– [Students] (chanting in unison) Boogeyman! Boogeyman! Jamie's uncle's a boogeyman!
– [Girl] How come your Mommy didn’t make
you a costume, Jamie?
– [Boy] How could she? Her Mom is dead!
(meme laugh)
– Jamie runs away trying to stifle what looks
like a panic attack. When Rachel picks her
up from school, with her friend Lindsey, they
drive to get some ice-cream. Jamie expresses
that she now wants to participate in Halloween,
where she had not shown any previous interest.
Oh good, we don’t have to slit her throat. It’s
clear that Jamie wants to fit in with the other
kids. Rachel takes her to buy a Halloween costume
and she chooses a clown costume, very similar to
the one Michael wore as he stabbed his sister
Judith, when he was Jamie’s age in the 60s.
Jamie looks in the mirror to admire the
costume but instead she sees Michael Myers
in her reflection. Jamie is aware of what
Michael looked like as a child, because
she has a shoebox at home full of old photos,
which not only includes pictures of her Mom,
but also this shot of the prepubescent
Michael, which is more evidence that Laurie
probably did tell her the truth about her uncle.
As she starts to hyperventilate and panic,
she turns around to see the adult
Michael Myers standing behind her.
She freaks out, getting the attention of
everyone around her and Michael disappears.
Rachel tries to comfort Jamie as they leave. We
never actually see them pay for the costume, so,
I guess Rachel and Jamie are just shoplifters now.
Darlene and Richard go out that evening, leaving
Rachel to take Jamie trick-or-treating. She
actually makes peace with some of the kids
that were picking on her at school and ends
up joining their group. They arrive at the
Meekers’ house, where they’re greeted by
Rachel’s classmate, Kelly Meeker, wearing
only her Cops Do It By The Book Shirt,
which I’m gonna put on over my clothes right now
because I need more excuses to wear this thing.
Rachel gets upset when she sees the boy she’s
interested in, Brady, emerge from the hallway,
making it clear that they were probably hooking
up. As Rachel storms off in a fit of JGS,
Brady chases after her, but Jamie doesn’t
realize and continues on with her new friends.
She soon finds herself separated; lost on
Halloween night with a killer on the loose.
(cinematic impact)
(ominous guitar music)
As trick-or-treaters vacate the streets,
Rachel and Jamie try to find each other.
Jamie thinks she’s being followed, but luckily
for her, Rachel finds her and the Haddonfield
police find both of them just in time.
As they pull away, they’re surrounded by
pranksters dressed up as Michael Myers, which
seems to be a Darwin Award waiting to happen.
– [Dr. Loomis] Dear God.
(Draws his gun)
– Hey, don’t shoot!
– While it seems as if no damage is done this
time, for Jamie, who is already struggling to
decipher what’s real and what’s a dream, this only
leaves her feeling more scared and confused.
After discovering that the police station
has already been ravaged by Michael Myers,
Sheriff Meeker takes Jamie, Rachel and Dr.
Loomis to his own house for safety. Jamie
is ushered upstairs to get some rest and
Rachel tries to comfort her. At some point,
Jamie does appear to fall asleep, so
Rachel heads downstairs to investigate.
The sheriff assigns an officer to keep watch at
the front door, and Loomis leaves to go back to
Jamie’s house, hoping he can catch Michael
Myers there. The Sheriff gets word that the
local Illinois boys from the bar accidentally
killed a guy and leaves to address this,
so Jamie’s life is now in the hands of a bunch
of teenagers and a single police officer.
Noises downstairs wake her up, and she
realizes Rachel is gone, which discomforts her,
and she comes out of the upstairs bedroom just
in time to her adoptive sister rushing back to
her in a panic, which is a relief until she
realizes that Michael Myers isn’t far behind.
She actually witnesses Brady’s
head getting literally ripped off,
as if there wasn’t enough
for her to be traumatized by.
– [Announcer] “Here comes the
rush and here’s the hit; OH!”
– Uhh, not that Brady. Jamie and Rachel are chased
into the attic and they’re able to escape to the
roof, but Michael follows them, and the only way
she’s able to get away is John McClane style.
– I promise I will never even think about
going up on a tall building again.
– Rachel isn’t so lucky.
(Rachel screaming)
(thud)
Jamie cries and begs Rachel to please
“come alive” but Rachel is unresponsive,
so Jamie is left all alone with Michael coming
down to get her. She runs away screaming for
help when she is forcefully grabbed
by another terrifying figure: Loomis.
– What are you doing out here, alone?
– Everybody’s dead! I just want to go home.
– No, no. You can’t. I’ve just been there.
That’s the first place he’ll look for you.
– No, we just established that that’s not the
first place he looked for her. Instead,
he decides to take Jamie to the school.
They break in and Loomis may have one
of the worst poker faces I’ve ever
seen while trying to comfort her.
– [Loomis] We’ll hear some sirens, soon.
– [Jamie] And We’ll be safe?
– Yes.
– You don't believe that. Do you?
– NO.
– Unsurprisingly, Michael Myers breaks in
almost immediately and incapacitates Loomis,
leaving Jamie trapped in the school. As
she tries to run away she falls down the
stairs and hurts herself, where Michael is
able to grab her. Rachel suddenly appears,
alive. This is why you gotta check for a pulse. She
blinds Michael with a fire extinguisher and
they flee the school to find the protection
of the Illinois boys. Apparently the Sheriff
never found them and killing a guy
didn’t deter them from continuing.
Little do they know, Michael Myers
hitched a ride on the bottom of
their truck and eventually gets the
driver. All of this results in Jamie
being turned into a human pinball
between the seat glove compartment
(pinball game noises)
...and Rachel taking the wheel to do this.
(screeching brakes)
And this.
– [Homer Simpson] I have road rage and I know how to use it!
– [Zac] Causing him to fall over into a
roadside ditch as state police
arrive. Rachel yells at Jamie to stay in
the car, but she doesn’t. At this point,
she’s been smashed around a car, so
she might still be a little bit hazy.
She takes Michael’s hand and has an
expression of trying to understand him.
I’m sure there are different interpretations of
what exactly transpires between the two here,
but I’ve always seen it as Michael passing part of
his curse onto her, based on what goes down next.
Jamie and Rachel return home to Darlene and
Richard. As Darlene is drawing Jamie a bath,
almost robotically in a manner very
similar to Michael Myers’s behaviour,
Jamie puts back on the clown mask. She picks up
the scissors from a counter and Darlene screams.
Only this time, it is revealed to be Jamie who
stabbed her. She stands at the top of the stairs
in her clown costume, weapon in hand, just as
Michael did in front of his house back in 1963.
The same evil that has controlled Michael
all these years has seemingly now affiliated
Jamie. There is even a point later on where
Loomis implies that Michael “made her do it.”
– What about your stepmother, Jamie? You love her,  don't you? He made you stab her.
– ...which kind of implies that he’s referencing
Jamie’s account of what went on that night.
Jamie develops this connection to Michael Myers.
Dr. Loomis, having been so close to the evil for
so many years, seems to understand the nature of
what’s going on with her, but from the point of
view of anyone else, her behaviour would quickly
be diagnosed as a reaction to emotional trauma.
However, according to The Child Mind Institute,
violent behavior is not a typical reaction to
childhood trauma. So the most likely scenario is
that her behaviour was attributed to her physical
injuries, like when her head SLAMMED against
the glove compartment. According to a study at
The University of Michigan, “young people
who suffered a recent head injury (within
a year of being questioned for the study) were
even more likely to report violent behavior.”
She also loses the ability to speak, another
parallel shared between her and Michael Myers,
who never spoke again after his childhood
outburst of aggressive behaviour in ‘63. With
Jamie seemingly following in her family member’s
footsteps, a bleak future for her looks imminent,
but one key difference between the two
would send her down a different path.
(cinematic impact)
(mysterious music)
Luckily for Jamie, she is not given the same
treatment that her Mom’s brother was given
25 years before. Instead of being shipped out
to Smith’s Grove or another mental facility,
she gets to stay nearby, and checks
into the Haddonfield Children’s Clinic.
Over the course of the next year, she
would receive treatment there while also
going to school with the other patients. She
became close with a boy named Billy Hill,
who had a bad stutter, causing the two
to bond over their speech issues. It
seems like the two have kind of a puppy-love
relationship going on by the next school year.
– [Tina] Billy is going to have
to fight off a lot of boys.
– Dr. Loomis takes up the job as her psychiatrist,
which I’m surprised her step-parents were OK with
given that Loomis nearly tried to shoot
her at one point after realizing she was
carrying the evil, and she’s also tended
to by other staff members of the clinic.
Rachel came to visit her regularly and sometimes
brought her friend Tina to
help keep Jamie company.
Jamie continues to be haunted by nightmares,
and they appear to have gotten more severe,
causing her to thrash around in her sleep and
relive her attack against her step-mother.
After one such terror on October 30th 1989, Jamie
woke up trying to scream, but not being able to
produce any sound. All of the trauma from the
year before has manifested itself in Jamie in
what’s referred to as “selective mutism.”
According to the Cedars-Sinai Health Library,
“the main sign of selective mutism is
a month or more of failure to speak
only in certain social situations.” The condition
is still being studied today for possible causes,
but researchers have identified a number
of them, one of which is selective mutism
as a result of a traumatic experience, which
needless to say, fits Jamie’s case pretty well.
Another possible factor is poor family
relationships. Jamie’s uncle tried to kill
her 3 times, so again, she more than qualifies.
It is also noted that selective mutism can run in
the family, which could also be relevant because
Michael hasn’t spoken since he was 6 years old.
In the original timeline there’s a supernatural
reason for this, which seems to apply to both him
and Jamie in relation to the Curse of Thorn.
There is a difference between them though,
because Michael doesn’t appear
to really ever attempt to speak,
and Jamie tries to speak unsuccessfully.
Her willingness to fight back against her
circumstances may have something to do with why
she has not become a lost cause like Michael has.
The hereditary explanation for Jamie’s
silence could also help explain this moment,
where Jamie’s mother seemed to have
a temporary bout of mutism, herself.
– H-help...
– Jamie comes to the realization that her newfound
connection to Michael also allows her to see
through his eyes. While she can not speak, she
is able to write down, “He’s coming for me.”
But the orderlies are more concerned about her
intense episode, and this detail is overlooked.
Hours later, after Jamie is stabilized, she wakes
up to a Halloween morning visit from Rachel, Tina,
and her doberman pinscher, Max.
Rachel brings her a new costume,
which Jamie is excited to try out until Dr. Loomis
appears in an almost villainous fashion. Why’s
he always gotta be wearing that jacket, even
when he’s inside and it looks uncomfortable?
Rachel explains she’s leaving town for a couple
days, but they’re interrupted by a rock smashing
through Jamie’s window. An attached note reads:
“The Evil Child Must Die.” The public has come
to see Jamie as a second coming of Michael
Myers, which adds to her distress and makes her
unwilling to vent her issues with her doctor,
perhaps out of fear that opening up will make
her seem like even more of a freak. It doesn’t
help that Loomis is like a maniac in this one.
(maniacal laughter)
That morning during art class, she
visualizes Michael Myers trying to get
into her house while Rachel is showering,
and sees Max furiously barking at him.
She frantically draws a picture of Max, which
Billy notices and communicates to Loomis,
who calls Rachel and tells
her to get out of the house.
Once she’s safe, Loomis tries
to assure Jamie that it’s OK,
but Jamie knows something is still wrong. Loomis
begs her to help communicate with writing.
– Tell me what you know! Here! Write! Write! Write!
– He sounds like my YouTube commenters
trying to get me to do a video on Candyman.
– Write! Write! Write!
– This is a lot of responsibility to put on a child,
and Jamie shuts down. That afternoon, she has
another nightmare with seizure-like symptoms,
as she sees Michael stabbing her step-sister
to death with a pair of scissors.
However, because her dream earlier that day did not lead to the police finding Michael Myers,
she's kind of unsure if this is real or not.
In the afternoon, she dreams through Michael’s
eyes again and sees him stalk Tina and her friend
Sammy on their way to the clinic to visit her.
As she panics in her sleep, Tina’s boyfriend,
coincidentally also named Michael, pulls up
and unintentionally saves them just in time.
But when Jamie wakes up, she knows Michael is out
there and as she struggles to the window, she sees
him lurking in the tree outside and freaks
out. She believes he’s chasing her and hides
in the basement, only to realize she has been
being followed by the janitor of the facility,
which is less scary if only slightly. The janitor
doesn’t know sign language, so Jamie’s is sent
back to bed where Loomis checks on her, once again
looking for answers about where Michael Myers is.
Their interaction makes me wonder how this man
has ever been permitted to work with children.
– [Dr. Loomis] Today in the cemetery, somebody dug up a
coffin. It was a coffin of a nine year old girl.
What do you think he’s going to do with that?
– Also, I don’t know how Jamie’s
age skipped an entire year from
seven years old to nine years
old the following Halloween?
– [Tina] Jamie’s a 9-year-old girl!
– [Loomis] You are nine years old!
– It’s possible that Tina and Dr.
Loomis were just rounding up;
like if Jamie was born in November
or December. That way she still would
have been seven in October 1988, then in
1989 she’d be eight, but about to turn 9.
So they might refer to her as a 9 year old.
In the evening, Jamie and Billy participate in a
Halloween pageant put on by the children’s clinic
and Jamie has yet another episode. She sees
Tina getting into a car with Michael Myers,
and her reaction is so severe that Jamie
nearly throws herself over the railing.
With the help and patience of Billy, she’s
able to mutter the word “store”. Following
a very frustrating game of charades and
a couple more audible clues from Jamie,
Loomis and the Sheriff determine which store
-- a gas station that Tina has stepped into.
The cops are able to pick her up
and safely bring her to the clinic.
When Tina arrives, Jamie is able to speak
her name and Tina is thrilled and shocked
to see Jamie talking again. This is a big
breakthrough, and lines up with what we know
about selective mutism, which can be exacerbated
by stress. It makes sense that Jamie is able to
speak again after the huge relief of seeing
Tina is OK, and it also makes sense why she
has difficulty speaking around Dr. Loomis:
the guy’s not exactly putting her at ease.
However, just because Jamie can talk,
doesn’t mean that the adults around her
will necessarily listen. As Jamie tries to
tell Tina that she was with The Boogeyman,
Tina brushes it off and decides to head out
to her Halloween party. This leaves Jamie
stressed but determined to protect her. As Tina
leaves, Loomis instructs two police officers
to follow her. Billy overhears where she’s
going and relays this information to Jamie,
so they both sneak out to head toward
the farm where more danger would await.
(cinematic impact)
(suspenseful music)
When Jamie and Billy arrive at The
Tower Farm, Michael Myers has already
claimed four victims and is targeting
a fifth in Tina, but Jamie screams out.
– Leave her alone!
– This is another important step for Jamie’s
recovery, as she’s now not only able to speak,
but do so very loudly and in the most stressful
scenario imaginable. Michael diverts his attention
onto Jamie and Billy. After Jamie’s quick
cutbacks send Michael crashing into a tree,
she finds herself unable to find her footing
and it looks like he’s actually going to get
her this time until Tina sacrifices herself
to give her young friend a chance to escape.
Loomis arrives with the police and
asks Jamie if she will now agree to
help him and she agrees to go along with his plan.
This involves Loomis using Jamie as bait at
the old Myers’ house, and we’re just supposed
to ignore the fact that this looks nothing
like the Myers house. In another episode,
Jamie sees Michael back at the clinic and fears
for Billy’s safety, so the police protecting the
perimeter outside go back over there to try to
catch Michael. However, Michael sneaks back to
the house anyway and Jamie witnesses the last
officer left to protect her getting pounded on
her masked adversary, so she gets out of there and
tries to play a dangerous game of hide-and-seek.
Michael quickly discovers her in the laundry
chute, so she lets go and rides down it. Let’s
face it, we ALL wanted to do this at some
point as a kid. If you didn’t you’re lame.
She’s only able to get away by climbing back up,
then running upstairs where comes
upon the bodies of Max and Rachel.
Even after everything she’s been through, I’m
tempted to say this was the most traumatic,
because Rachel was the one person who was there
for her to keep her safe no matter what when
Michael initially came after her. She also notices
the coffin that Loomis told her about earlier,
which I just made the connection that that’s
what he was referring to. She climbs inside,
essentially suggesting she’s going to give herself
up to him, but before he takes her life, she has a
moment with her uncle, not the empty, faceless
killer, but the rarely seen human side of him.
– Let me see.
(heavy breathing)
You’re just like me.
This moment of emotionality is cut short
however, when Jamie touches him and the rage
consumes him once more. Michael goes berserk
and Jamie just narrowly gets away to retreat
to the arms of Dr. Loomis, but to her horror, he
actually picks her up and offers her to Michael.
– You want her! Here she is.
– Loomis is really just using her as bait to
lure Michael into this trap he has set up,
but as far as I can tell, Jamie was not in
on it. I say that because the panic we see
from her seems so genuine. If you think about
it, this is just so immoral on Loomis’s part
and probably very damaging for Jamie’s mental
health, if that’s even a thing at this point.
She just got her voice back a couple of
hours ago. She lost her adoptive sister,
her dog, and her friend, who gave it
all up to protect her. And now Loomis,
who she’s literally just learned to trust
for the first time -- and by the way is
her psychiatrist (!) and is literally supposed to be the one
protecting her from emotional trauma – ends up
being the one to cause her a great deal
of emotional distress because he is now
more obsessed with destroying his former
patient than helping his current one.
Despite the damage this might have done
Jamie, Michael is captured by the police
and taken to jail -- so it seems as if the
whole nightmare may be over for Jamie Lloyd.
She’s escorted to the back of a police car,
as things are sorted out in the station, when
suddenly, they hear an explosion inside, which the
cop goes to check one. Jamie gets out of the car,
directly disobeying what the cop told her, but
whatever, and goes inside to find that the rest
of the police force has been massacred and Michael
has been broken out of captivity once more.
– [Jamie] (crying) No...
– Jamie is not seen again for the next six years.
– [Tommy] Six years ago, on Halloween night,
Michael and Jamie vanished. Many people believed
them dead, but I think someone hid them away.
– This suggests that the man that freed Michael,
who we later find out to be Dr. Terrance Wynn,
kidnapped her shortly after, and kept her
hidden underground at Smith’s Grove Sanitarium.
Michael’s human sacrifices are tied to the
curse placed on him by The Cult of Thorn.
As a result, he only appears when the
Thorn constellation can be seen in the
sky, and that doesn’t happen
again until October of 1995.
It is not clear how she became pregnant. There
are a lot of theories, but I don’t think any
of them can be proven, and none of them seem
to involve Jamie getting pregnant by choice,
so since there’s nothing for me to
analyze here, let’s just move on.
On October 30th, 1995, Jamie gave birth to
her son, who would later be named Stephen.
The cult takes the baby away from her, but
midwife who assisted with the delivery is
secretly on her side and makes an effort to
help her escape the sanitarium with her son.
This is presumably the first time she’s gotten out
in public since she was a little
kid, but unfortunately for her,
she is not the only one who is unleashed
that night. Michael is sent to go after her.
She makes her way to an empty bus
station. Unable to get through to police,
she does the next best thing and calls
into a radio show, which is discussing
Haddonfield and Michael Myers, seeing
as this is the day before Halloween.
– [Jamie] It’sMichael.
Michael Myers. Look, someone, anyone,
help me. Dr. Loomis are you out there? Can you
hear me Dr. Loomis, I need your help.
– [Barry] Please, please, no, no stop
this. What the hell is going on tonight?
– Knowing that Michael is not far behind
her, she hides the baby in a bathroom
and gets as far away as possible in order to
lure Michael away from the baby. She ends up
getting run off the road near a farm
and tries to hide inside of the barn.
As she looks for another hiding spot, she
realizes that Michael is looking for her.
Under normal circumstances, Jamie probably
would have run away on foot again, but this
time things are different, because she just
gave birth no more than a couple of hours ago.
Usually a woman is confined to a couple of days of
bedrest after giving birth, so the fact that she’s
even able to be on her feet and moving around
is probably a result of motherly adrenaline.
Adrenaline comes from the hormone epinephrine
in our brains produced to increase the blood flow
to our muscles and heart rate. When you
hear about a fight-or-flight response in
humans or in animals, that’s adrenaline
kicking in to try to save our lives.
It’s thought that a mother possesses a survival
instinct not only for her, but also for her child,
sometimes drawing extra strength
that she does not seem to otherwise possess.
Jamie seems to use this strength to push
her through the post delivery exhaustion,
hide her baby lure Michael as
far away as possible. But now,
her body can take her no further, and
Haddonfield’s boogeyman catches up with her.
(stinger)
(choking sounds)
As she is impaled on… apparently this
thing is a corn thresher... she tries
to reach out to Michael the same way that she did
as a child but this time, gets no sympathy.
The last thing she says is, “you can’t have
the baby Michael,” and realizing that she’s
no longer useful to him, he turns on
the machine to rip apart her insides.
Jamie Lloyd’s story is a tragic
one. At only seven years old,
her life completely changed when she lost
her parents, was attacked by her uncle,
and developed stress related speech issues as
she watched nearly everyone close to her die.
But if there is one silver lining, one takeaway
about her character, it’s that she found herself
in exactly the same scenario as Michael
Myers, but didn’t follow in his footsteps
to become Haddonfield’s next boogeyman. As
difficult as it may have been, she recovered,
and refused to succumb to the evil, even using her
connection to Michael as an advantage against him.
But I guess if there’s a lesson to be
learned here, it’s that Loomis should
never work with children. To see my lessons
on Loomis and other Halloween characters,
click that playlist on the left. Let me know who
else you’d like to see covered here on Horror
History and remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
and make sure you select ALL notifications. I will
see you in the next one. Assuming we both survive.
(upbeat kazoo music)